hi Jonathan George Carlin I'm getting
ready to clear out of town tomorrow
night so I just want to repeat to you
how how much I [ __ ] enjoyed your show
and how thoroughly entertaining and
brilliant it is but the opening page
tableau had just lovely just like I was
a bomb and I shouldn't have it's great
I just [ __ ] everything I love you I
mean
crazy it's riding on the surface of my
arm
it's not penetrating my arm that would
be real this is an illusion this is real
[Music]
it's a track crazy I mean crazy I think
I mean mentally ill with two words right
[Music]
[ __ ] up is towards guess we're go with
crazy you want to play this one come to
come here come here come here this is a
fun game put this lift up your shirt put
this down
put your head back okay now you got to
make this white thing fall in the funnel
and if it does you win so many that come
into mind I've had to say hysterical and
big-hearted
Oh sir you have a handkerchief all right
do this you got something hanging on
your nose
I'm sorry but it's really bugging me
wipe it off
self-destructive is that two words I
think that's two words right
self-destruct his work is so original he
can pick up a piece of trash on the
ground and and like wave it in front of
your face and make us all laugh excuse
me something in my nose
[Applause]
he's just goofy that's what I can say
and I love that sorry all right
outside their inch just by taking the
money out on the back pocket there prop
comedy was always kind of wonderful to
watch but maybe not the most respected
by being a magician he had the excuse to
do comedy with props and it was kind of
okay check this out how's the clown Oh
wait there's a note I can't take that
song anymore friend to me friend trick
entertainer whose bizarre humor and
antics have made him famous all over the
world we're talking about the amazing
Jonathan I retired I don't do shows
anymore
he decided to go back out and do one
last tour there's a very special evening
for me tonight because I've known
Jonathan for so long and seen him done
so many amazing things but I've seen him
really up against it of late and the
fact that he's coming out here tonight
to perform for you is one of the most
amazing things I have ever seen ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
I feel great that he's gonna have the
opportunity to get back on stage but I
know he loves doing and do what I know
he's great at Jonathan going out there
and just being in the moment is a
particularly wonderful a beautiful thing
[Music]
zelich all right
palm up pinched you here love and your
finger and pull out magic is my life
what is magic to me haven't you see my
magic it's everything I went to jail
once and saved me in jail when they all
started coming at me
I showed him card tricks you know and
that took their mind off me being anally
raped for a couple minutes
I say he's me from tickets every bad
thing you can always get out of it by
doing a stupid trip he was a good kid I
sent him to the magic store a lot to buy
these little magic tricks and he got
very very interested in it and I was
glad to some extent that kept him out of
trouble
what kind of trouble was he getting into
smoking a lot of pot
not the best student but that didn't
really matter in the long run well every
high school class has a class clown that
kid who will do just about anything to
gross out the girls and impress the guys
one of them grew up to be called the
amazing Jonathan when I was in ninth
grade I did a trick where I'd bent to
spoon for my physics teacher it's a
trick I just do a misdirection but he
asked me is this is this real can you
really do this or is it just a trick and
I was really a bad student I wasn't that
wasn't real popular so I lied to him and
I said I can really do it and he said he
want like wow right and I thought well
that's the end of that next hour I get a
call here or with this school in a cup
well John's Alice please come to
principals office plays as far as I
thought it said something to do with the
[ __ ] spoon thing I know it
there's my mom my dad the principal and
a reporter from the small little
newspaper in my time I'm like [ __ ] they
took my dad out of work there's a bunch
of spoons on the desk we want you to
bend these spoons my mom takes me aside
she says don't lie to me tell me was he
lying or was can you really do this and
I looked at right knee eye and I said I
could really do this yeah I was a very
gullible mother watch the spoon it's a
real metal spoon and yet it will bet I
proceeded to bend all these spoons and
freak them out they're looking at me
with this hall news all new respected
I've even told my neighbors I never been
so embarrassed in all of my life already
as I concentrate it starts to bend here
but I had to get out of it all the
magicians are gonna bust me if they see
this come out in the paper all the local
magicians are just gonna go he's a dick
he's lying just don't take your eyes off
the spoon
listen I don't want to be a freak in
school I just wanna be a normal kid and
my mom thought I understand and she told
him there's no story coming out you're
not gonna do the story I felt like a
fool but of course it leaked a week
later I was so popular in it they gave
me a tension it was like I had no I had
the power man I was a horrible magician
I was the worst magician ever but I
thought I was gonna be the next
Copperfield I said we'll do that do you
- I did a talent show from my high
school my family was there my friends
were there
everybody was there to see me do the
show before the show he was very upbeat
because he figured he had it all down
pat and I bombed so [ __ ] completely
bombed just 100% bomb nothing work six
tricks six tricks went wrong yellow team
went wrong I killed a dove the bird ran
away from me I went to chase it and it
stopped and I ran over it it's smashed
it like what what's this kid doing I
[ __ ] a levitation up there's a sheet
covering this levitation and you stand
behind the floating girl and lift the
sheet up well behind your leg is a giant
steel bar that's holding her up they
don't see it but the sheet was up the
whole time so all the time I'm walking
around they see this steel bar I'm
pulling the supports out one and then
the other side they see the steel bar
and then I go to lift the sheet up and I
realized that it's already been up the
whole time like okay [ __ ] I'm out bye
I'm done I was so upset for him and my
my neighbors were there after that night
I decided okay you're not gonna be a
great magician try something else
and John left home when he was 18 I was
kind of glad to see him get out of
Frasier and get away from the lot of
those kids and was hanging out with and
I figured it was a good experience for
him so we hitchhiked this is when you
could still hitchhike we hitchhiked to
San Francisco and I saw some street
performers
doing magic a Whitney Browne was out
there Madame flowers and wailing man a
lot of great acts and I would watch them
and go me you know I should try to do
magic again but I should try doing it
with the comedy like these guys are
doing because people aren't there to see
you
they're there to go shopping you know
you'd start a show in the beginning and
they would halfway through it they'd
they'd all wander off
you're like [ __ ] I'm doing the show
you start again mid wander off so to get
their attention you had to be good I
mean this is during the drought so I was
like taking buckets of water pouring
them out if you don't stop I'm pouring
all these [ __ ] the water out grabbing
a little kid and getting him in a
headlock with a knife I'll kill this kid
does anything funny that make them stop
I was doing the razor blade trick where
I swallow razor blades and then swallow
thread them and bring them up all thread
who do you need to do it some guy came
up to me and said you know I got a blood
capsule you should do that with a blood
capsule that would be funny and I said
give me one I'll try it
so as I'm chewing it I talked about how
it's easy for me because I practice and
remember I'm off starts turning red and
I notice that I've cut my mouth little
drool and then discussions you know you
gotta start like oh [ __ ] I got myself no
no the magic comedy was always magic
that didn't work or imagine it wasn't
really real and that was maybe some of
that and Jonathan this stuff but but
mostly it was this force of nature
coming at you that was like this big
steamroller that kept attacking you it
was very fresh my moley
okay can I say and one of her cards are
in the plot Oh would you mix them around
please bringing my app from the streets
to the nightclubs was like wise they've
taken a tornado putting it in a job
people are going like this guy's [ __ ]
insane you know which I was very good
magical boy he's actually a very good
magician there's really nice ideas you
know the the best stuff that Jonathan
does it's the stuff he comes up with
really just while walking on stage
pretty much I mean he can throw together
some sort of prank very very quickly
that is really of the moment I think I'm
more of a comedian I have more comic
ability than I do magic ability and any
magician would agree with me there
working at a strip club up in Alaska I
had to come out between every girl and
do it show it's like you want to see
some titties first here's a magician
that was my intro you know they didn't
want to [ __ ] see myself I was dying up
there
I memorized fifty insult lines comebacks
and I was sharper that I've ever been I
got to be what they were happy seeing me
and that I knew that I was fast enough I
can handle anything but why did the holy
city zoo the first night I did Robin
Williams was a Robin came in and dis at
Danny poverty was there and I was there
and we were all just starting out Paula
Poundstone Ellen DeGeneres a lot of
people that became really really famous
we're from the same cloth that
generation of comedy work in that comedy
club pretty good time for comedy clubs
were springing up everywhere in the
United States
I could go work as much as I wanted I
never auditioned for TV I was always a
street performer than a club performer
they wanted three comics to go from San
Francisco to represent San Francisco and
go to the Improv for a showcase big
showcase take my clothes off and run
around let's prevent streaking
did the showcase and destroy it they'd
have never seen anything like that game
prime and one night I got David
Letterman Jonathan thank you very much
nice job I got Thicke of the night I got
HBO young comedians special which I can
it was absolutely amazing
now he started as a street performer in
San Francisco working for spare change
would you please welcome the
inspirational lunacy of the amazing
Jonathan
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going to do is I'm going to go into
the audience and I'm going to ask for
somebody to come up and help me out it
can be anybody at all you want to help
me just say something and you can come
up it can be anyone can I go in - sure
come on
and after that it was just that was it I
didn't have to wait long for the draw to
come in
I went from hey hey I treated that comic
- hey aren't you the amazing Jonathan
[Applause]
oh boy oh boy I find an introduction
like that every time I came on stage I'd
be pissed this is a meat skewer hold
your hand out well what you do is you do
what I've done here as I've invented
this new little ultra-thin briefcase to
keep my ball
[Music]
[Applause]
where's out your card
a lot of people did trying to do magic
and it's just not working anymore you
have to have something that gives you
the edge and the bloody tricks it seems
to be what they want right now
he takes the worst parts of other magic
acts and makes them actually a good part
of his very carefully we place it
underneath and they restores back into
one piece imagine trying to act Pleasant
audience members well essentially doing
something deeply unpleasant and it
crosses over into something really
beautiful and really funny sometimes
magic sounds like pain as Jerry Seinfeld
said all magic is here's a quarter now
it's gone you're a jerk that's back
you're an [ __ ] show's over Jonathan
does that even more for this though I
would like the lights taken down a
little bit to add to the effect we have
some strobe lights but to really make
this look cool can you take the lights
down a little bit please just perfect
thank you let's turn the lights down
just a bed if you could dim them yeah
just like that perfect take the lights
all the way down if you could
Jonathan performance has the homemade
feeling it's good but it's you know it's
a little bit oh man what diagnosed right
over here he makes sure he doesn't have
that polish I can do whatever I want to
an audience member they trust Andrew and
they laugh Trust is an important thing
drink it Sandra you put the LSD in there
well you should start to fill out any
second now
any second
[Applause]
okay he looked a little weird for a
second ladies Jonathan it was doing very
very well
Merv Griffin kind of fell in love with
him right and so he was even hosting a
game show they get a call from Merv
going ooh I have an idea you're gonna be
the star of my new game show and I'm
like I'm not really a game show host
material you know you know I based this
on your show so you're gonna be perfect
[Applause]
breakfast with me driving that show it
was great it was like a groundbreaking
game show
you did it in his thousand seat showroom
and he packed the people and they've got
a really huge underground following they
got bought and we did it on NBC for 60
episode and you gotta help me out on
this one just turn okay
get over here get over here okay turn
your face that way now you got to just
face this way so it's better if you face
this way okay now first brush the hair
out of your eyes okay perfect ready
let's get the shot and and come look
this way and brush the hair out of your
eyes okay does this one that you drive
now when I started working with Jonathan
a long time ago I would hear about Jill
Osbourne this Jill Osbourne from
Australia and like all the adventures
that they went through and Jonathan
would like dare him to do all kinds of
crazy things and I'm like wow and he did
it yeah he actually did it
they're just like a team you know like
always laughing bantering back and forth
kind of like brothers but then almost
like father-son as well Joel was was the
amazing Johnathan show he was the the
backbone of the show it wouldn't go on
without him the reason I think they came
into each other's lives is because Joel
had an obsession with Johnathan when he
was just a kid
Joel Osbourne was a little creepy kid
who used to camp out in front of my
hotel room and called me on the phone
whenever he could I didn't know he was
is this a little kid but he would camp
out in front of my hotel room with his
friends and then when I come out he
would have me sign stuff and and I would
humor him the first time second time
third time got a little creepy
my dad got us tickets to go see the
amazing Jonathan I didn't know who
Jonathan was my dad drives us up to
Kings Cross where all the brothels and
strip clubs and late-night bars of
Sydney were situated and that's of
course where Jonathan was putting on his
first season of shows in Sydney there
was a massive poster the entrance with
the amazing Jonathan written on it said
the madman of American comedy and him
doing the eyebrow thing and I'm blood
coming out of his now I'm thinking wow I
saw this about who's this guy it was
like a freight train it was like nothing
else I experienced like he just sucked
all the energy and just then just
released it back onto the audience and I
was like just dying throughout the show
watching this guy up there just like he
gets a volunteer up from the audience
and puts him through the wringer and and
and and also to clocking the audience to
watching Jonathan I'd never been around
and heard laughter not only had I
laughed that hard but hearing you know a
few hundred people laughing that hard
around me as well it was the energy in
the room was just overwhelming and and
me sitting there as a 12 year old with a
pin spot on me just watching Jonathan on
stage thinking that's what I want to do
when I grow up so I call up the the
comedy venue again and I said I want to
find out Jonathan's got a fan club and
he said I don't know he said um he's
staying at the Siebel town house
give him a call I remember you yes it
was this morning yes yeah remember and
he said what are you doing tomorrow
night I said ah nothing and he said well
I got my last show why don't I put your
name on the door you come along and so I
cannot bring my mom and he said yeah
sure I put the tickets under your name
they'll be on the door and I was so
excited I sent him letters never heard
back from him nothing then he got a
commercial for me
his dad was an advertising exec he
called me up and said you want to do
this commercial
it pays his $60,000 for one day's taping
I'm like maybe this isn't a creepy
little kid so I went and did the taping
I was kind of nervous to go up and talk
to him but I got to the break and
everyone left then I go and walk off to
the side of the stage and I run into
someone and I apologized and looked up
and there's Jonathan standing in front
of me I said I know this kid I'll show
him some magic I kneeled down and showed
him some magic on the ground
picked it up real quick and he and er I
liked the kid it was really nice
we hung out the rest of the day whenever
he had a break would go to the dressing
room and chat more and he was a
sweetheart just you know it wasn't
creepy at all till I got to his room
once
and it was like an altar
I remember at the end he grabbed a piece
of paper and just seiner and just was
writing on this piece of paper and he
says you don't have to worry about
letters anymore
here keep in contact and that was the
last thing they need took off and I
looked down and had his home phone
number on that you know but with
Jonathan he's a big kid you know that we
connected it was we were like two kids
just hanging out we had shared similar
interests in in things from it maybe not
the drugs and porn but other than that
then one day I spoke to him and he said
listen I met this Australian girl named
Sandra I'm in love I'm gonna marry this
girl I am engaged to an Australian woman
her name is Sandra she's actually in the
audience with her parents and I love
Sandra because I she reminds me a lot of
myself we get along where she was right
there he's here
[Music]
[Applause]
he was coming out to Australia all the
time I remember the first time he he
called me up and said you know come on
over to Sandra's parents place I'm
sitting there you know there's geeky
fourteen-year-old kid hanging out my
wife loved yo I said come on with me
I'll give you a job and you can work for
me in the States and he's wasn't old
enough you know still at school don't
need school or quit school come tour
with the drug addict smoking a lot of
pot when I left school that was my first
time coming to America Jonathan so you
know I'll take care of everything just
get on out here and you know I'll take
care of the rest so I was staying with
him at his house in LA and he was
developing a magic kit at the time and
so I was seeing the ins and outs on
helping him in the garage make stuff I
went on the road with him and then at
the end of the trip he said you know I
do you think the magic kit would go in
Australia I said it would go great yes
you want to head up the company over
there yes so I went back to Australia
and suddenly I was setting up this weird
stuff magic company over there you're
coming out to Australia to do a massive
season in Sydney I'm 19 and you give me
the responsibility of managing and
promoting your season in Sydney and
there's a lot of money at stake here
there's a lot of you know I've never
done that before and you put that
responsibility forward to me but I knew
that that you would go around and do the
things that needed to be done and take
care of organised everything you know
you're a very organised kid
it was a success the following year he
had a falling-out with his manager he
said listen I've got no one to promote
or manage my next season in Sydney do
you want to do it all right
yes I did not knowing once again thrown
in the deep end it was such a
responsibility because he's like a three
week season in Sydney was on my
shoulders all the shows went great the
season was a huge success everyone made
a lot of money out of it and at the end
of it Jonathan said to me you want to
move out to the States and be my road
manager no yes I did I'm right it's it's
Joel I was born the man himself there is
finally comes to the stakes he's good he
works me he works great he does
everything perfect Joel's mom comes out
to visit and I get the classic Joel
story I don't know as Jonathan told you
the stories you know like about Jonathan
the stories are so tragic that I cried
laughing my parents separated when I was
four or five whose mom said you know the
divorce was very hard on Joel I used to
draw really well then after my dad left
I just draw stick man for some reason
that [ __ ] set me off laughing it and
I couldn't stop now we just gotta stick
minister this is [ __ ] lazy now is
that's not all is artistic ability gun
and I'm like mama why are you do not
tell him these stories and do okay but
you should just let me tell them about
Santa Claus I'm way yes tell me [ __ ]
Santa Claus
went to see Santa Claus you know he said
you know what do you want for christmas
you said all the all I want for
Christmas is for my dad to come over oh
poor little kid he would die laughing
that's really why he didn't get it the
one Jonathan really loves though was
when at school or at school the teacher
said okay class whose special and
everyone's hand went up except for
little Joel and Joel how come your hands
now why why why don't you think you're
special
well if I were special my dad wouldn't
have left like [ __ ] get over it already
[ __ ] you know I don't know I I guess I'm
glad someone got something out of my
childhood abandonment issues some of his
musical tastes sucked Billy Joel was my
least favorite you know Billy Joel was
the first concert I saw [ __ ] adrenaline
would come into the garage when I was
working and he'd be like what is this
[ __ ] how can you like this guy you know
we got arrested my my what they yeah for
loitering in front of a band that's
really droll the gel used to listen to
mark I'm and dancing queen by ABBA
I was like Jill's dad he took care of me
and I took care of Joel
Jonathan was very giving to Joel like
with his craft too and I think that's a
beautiful thing and I think that really
helped him as well with his career how
did you guys sustain me how did the
relationship work after I mean there's
there's Mary Todd wait that's how it
worked he enhanced his income quite a
bit from what I was paying him just by
taking my stupid bets I remember the
first bet were in Vaughn's in the in the
fresh produce department I said Joe
through all these three Tomatoes against
the supermarket wall power give you $200
and I thought okay all right you know
and I see Splatt Splatt Splatt and I
said Joe comes casually walking out did
it more money so that was the beginning
of basically my second income through
Jonathan then then shaving your head was
worth a thousand dollars he shaved his
head completely bald and I heard my wife
oh my god Joe from downstairs I went oh
I just lost $1,000 yeah there was a
sleeping bag in Santa Monica we're in
the road like all mud encrusted sleeping
bag was the most disgusting crusty
looking sleeping bag on La Brea just on
the side of the road and he goes you
crawl face-first into that sleeping bag
zip the sleeping bag up to your neck and
I'll give you $200 right that was the
bet I made so much money from these bets
over the years [ __ ] him fearless he
became fearless at this point he would
do anything to make some time food dick
it was a good threesome Joel my wife and
because those two loved each other and
they always had laughs and and it was
good for me because I didn't have to be
with either one of them Sandra will now
come out here come out here because
we're going to demonstrate trust all
right Sandra what I want you to do is
you trust me don't you place the pencil
in your mouth do not move from that spot
and you will not get hurt Hey
so I look down onto those yeah we did
looking at props for hours we've worked
on props that's it - I'd love to just
write material and work on building
stuff them yeah that was off my stood
the dismay of my ex-wife I didn't know
even had a marriage problem cuz our
always would say - Sandra are you happy
is everything okay and she was like yeah
everything's great
I'm the way home from Vegas one time
Sandra told me that she wanted a divorce
I'm like what and I remember walking up
to him at the baggage carrousel anyway
I'm out what are you talking about I go
Sandra she's left know what gone back to
the hotel no no she's she's she's
leaving me but you know [ __ ] it we got
home and her parents were staying at my
house she started packing I said if you
packed your to leave for good
I walk down the hallway past his doorway
and I looked in and I saw him in bed
with the 57 Magnum the one that Hunter
has Thompson had given to him and I got
Jonathan and he quickly takes the gun
and puts it underneath the underneath
the sheets and he yells out close the
[ __ ] bar and I wasn't gonna pull the
trigger but I just felt good to sit down
with that in my mouth just like the
drama of the situation Sandra's as white
as a ghost and she said I've just got
off the phone with Jonathan and he said
if I'm not in his life he's gonna wind
his and then I thought I have to tell
him what I think I just saw and I told
him everyone freaks out they called the
LAPD
I gotta go warn him his doors locked I'm
banging on the door yelling out Jonathan
Jonathan and he's not answering I ran
out onto the street suddenly out of
nowhere all these cops just descend on
me they've got their pistols out down
get down down on the ground down on the
ground I saw these flashlights in my
living room what the [ __ ] is that
I bet you it's the cops so I snorted my
last bit of speed real quick my bedroom
door comes down a boom they kick it down
tell me get out of ground get on the
ground
you got any drugs on whittling not
anymore you got a gun no they went under
my pillow first place they look that's
worth it that's where it was oh that one
yeah I got that word they bring Jonathan
out in handcuffs
all the cops are surrounding Jonathan
then one of them says haven't I seen you
on Comedy Central and the other one goes
you're the amazing Jonathan and I went
holy [ __ ] I'm saved one of the ten
people that saw my special it happened
to be a cop and then Jonathan goes well
if I was not amazing I could get out of
these handcuffs right all the cops start
laughing I'm thinking you know he's
working these cuts I said I wasn't gonna
shoot myself I was gonna shoot anybody
actually my wife that's right I said new
y'all laughter then eventually the
sergeant comes out to me and says listen
we've spoken with Jonathan he seems
alright alright I knew Joe was gonna
have to come back face me
he knew he's gonna be in trouble so I
decided to [ __ ] with him I took stage
blood when the cops left I splattered it
everywhere and I put my body under the
covers and a note on top of the body and
I waited just waited I walk up says
Jonathan the cops have rammed the door
his bedroom daughter so I looked through
it Jonathan Jonathan it's virtual
with his voice I could almost cry just
thinking about it it is good rocking
back and forth between Jonathan so
finally he approached the body and this
is blood everywhere pull out of the bed
up the back wall he's father know and he
picked it up be Joel I could no longer
stand listening to your shitty Billy
Joel music I hope you're happy now
Jonathan then they jumped down and went
ah he's laughing this blood everywhere
I'm in a state of shock I just walked up
to him and just hugged him and held him
and he just walked out and I didn't say
that one wasn't that funny we just
didn't talk about that again nobody said
a word about it for like a week
I'd do it again the next day if you fall
far again oh I knew it was over the top
but I wanted to be over the top if it
was anyone else it would be way too
thought it would be beyond acceptable
but because it's Jonathan what are you
gonna do during my divorce is the time
that was a strain for Joel he stayed
there for me despite all the [ __ ] I said
to him and all the [ __ ] I said to
everybody when I was going through that
divorce you know he stuck with me I'll
be saving my life through all that was
Jonathan and me and he wasn't in a good
way he would smoke crack regularly in
this specific corner of the room
[Music]
Jim Carrey was the fan balancing gets a
call one day from him and says I'm an
audition for this new role on in living
color the count of the day of the
audition Jonathan gets to the front door
then looks at the corner beside stopped
out and go smoke crack
I didn't want to work at all I did it's
just didn't want to work and gentle God
we talked me into going back out and
working again he was in the depths of
depression before a show he'd be
backstage and he would just break down
sobbing next to me and then he's
introduced and all right let's go do
this you know and then he'd come off and
he'd just been miserable again I got out
of antidepressants that's right he said
you don't get out of antidepressants I'm
leaving I was like I'm done I'm out and
I called Jonathan loved and he just was
really just down on the end of the phone
said Joel please come home come home so
I came home and he had a letter waiting
for me and and it's the only time he
ever apologized to move just explaining
where he's at and what he's going
through and how could you leave him like
that I you know I'd hate to think what
would have happened to him if he was
left alone by that point Jonathan had
been on the road for over 20 years and
he was over he was over the airport's
over the grind of touring we had done a
few runs in Vegas before like as a
Sahara two weeks would stretch into two
months because we were doing killer
business from Comedy Central specials we
were filling it up he got new management
a Gary propper and he said to Jonathan
what do you want and he said I don't
want to I don't want to be on the road
anymore I don't want to travel anymore
and Gary said well Vegas
we got various
they offered us two weeks at the Golden
Nugget fill in for David Brenner while
he was on vacation there it is the net
which at first thought is a hang on
downtown gold nugget like yeah that's
kind of going backwards is it well
Jonathan went downtown
I was just when downtown Vegas was
starting to have some sort of cachet it
was a reason to go down there I mean he
was pulling people down there that had
never been down there before we're gonna
start with a magic trick you have a
handkerchief sir do this and that two
weeks we sell out every night and they
didn't want David Brenner back but I
said David I'm not gonna do that to
David Brenner so they created a ten
o'clock time slot for me and we sold out
every night probably for a year and a
half for the free shirt how many animals
of each Moses take on the ark - none
because it was Noah at Moses sorry and
the Golden Nugget we changed their
demographic from an old folks home to
kids coming in and gambling it we did a
lot for that casino they treated us like
kings yeah Joel got his own room I got
my own room Pennock everybody got their
own room I got a suite we signed for
everything we did we'd have to pay for
anything he was killing it you know like
he was like packing out a casino every
night he had a girlfriend he was you
know living in the Scott fais suite and
we are in the Nugget I was living out my
merchandise bunny and putting a check
for a 40 50 grand in the bank every week
man we're gonna set up the motion does
we got three lots of mentioned dollars
and we got large shirts
Jonathan's weird stuff magic then we
done meth headbands we got books near my
paychecks we're just like holy yeah are
you serious
it was like I've used those stubs to dry
my tears now
I cry when I look at this stuff every
week for almost two years we would sign
things after the shows one person they
came up [ __ ]
my brother had cancer and right before
he died he came to see your show I never
saw him laugh that much and thank you
for doing that for him what do you do
when you come to a green light this TV
oh you call it a green light I think in
terms of practical jokes you know and
and and more and more I'd do that so
that's why I'm rigging my entire house
to be a big practical job that spider
was in my yard that's a real spy that's
a real spider
it was great it was the best time in my
life that was it can you remember this
for me
George to Lukey member 7 wants to see
the show just for one person I was
wanting to do my anything but working
for Jonathan was a 24/7 existence I
wanted to do comedy I wanted to be a
comedian you know then I started to
seeing him watch the comic you know for
me I was like mmm
something's gonna happen here eating
gonna be around very much longer
yeah I'd done everything I could with
Jonathan we'd been through everything we
had to it all over America we'd done the
casino run you know I'd seen a new city
every week and I knew he's fine
I need to go and do this it's time
Jonathan did Street performing so I
thought that's what I'm gonna do he had
high aspirations right from the start
nothing was gonna stop them nothing that
kind of driving somebody makes me sick
but yeah it was time for Jonah he's
living under my shadow in the class and
cafe at the Golden Nugget
he said something or other and my retort
to it was or maybe I should just go and
do my own thing then he said maybe and I
knew all right this is it that was that
and I left and moved back to back to
Australia the first show I ever seen him
do he was good he was doing props so I
got to help then you decided you didn't
want to do props he was too good to do
props anywhere you stand it like there's
not enough of those in the [ __ ] world
I planned on being in Vegas for three
months and that's it
and then going back to Toronto and being
able to charge more money for performing
because I could say performed in Vegas
but it didn't happen that way
I watched Jonathan's show and almost
peed myself he made me laugh a lot
actually and we hung out and he
basically was putting on all the charms
he told me who's gonna make me his wife
that night and told me that he loved me
and I was like what the [ __ ] is
happening here no my friends that I was
staying with they're like dude where are
you like are you okay this is Vegas and
you vanished I'm like yeah I'm living
with amazing Jonathan now we got married
June 14th three years ago and was it the
14th oh my god see it might be the
seventh and then those two dates stick
in my head I think 14th is my daughter's
respect I get those two confused a lot
briefly that's all we've been talking
about which is briefly [ __ ] let's go do
some drugs briefly and come back and
talk about something else you know it's
a tough subject I'm really anti anti
drugs I'd never I've never seen cocaine
in my life believe it or not you know
but even knowing that he would kind of
talk about it and he'd say good it's
great fantastic I've been doing drugs
since I was 16 years old man I started
doing drugs smoking a lot of pot then I
did a hit of mescaline and then I did
acid I just tried them all everything
but heroin all throughout my life I
would do it off on stage and people
wouldn't even know it
they said it's time for some magic dust
and I would do it like and people go
that's so funny he pretended like he
snorted coke wrong he snorted coke I
don't know when he's on it I truly do
that you know I'm of the mindset the
Dean Martin mindset that even if you're
doing drinking jokes in the show you're
not really a drunk you know I think it
would have been okay for him to you know
snort that whole bucket of white
material without having to really do it
but I'm in good company mom my heroes
were drug addicts week John Lennon all
the best of the Beatles did drugs and
Eric Clapton did drugs and and it's just
about every successful rock band that
was great did drugs because all in all
it makes you creative now let's look at
the list of people who don't do drugs
there's Richard Marx
[Applause]
there's Kenny G now I'm not trying to
promote drugs but who would you rather
hang out with seriously my feeling is
that Jonathan is about 50% of what he
could be if you've been sober his whole
life I can't think of one moment I've
heard from Jonathan that I don't think
would have been better without the drugs
I've heard other comedians say without
drugs they could not beat as funny as
they were whether that's true or not I
haven't got a clue
my thing is I may think that Jonathan's
better than Jonathan thinks he is
because I think that Jonathan without
drugs would have been really really
amazing I wish that wasn't part of his
life you know I really wish it does have
an effect it has that effect you know
there was a point where some of the
shows I could tell he was like getting
tired and like hard to breathe and he
was having trouble like you know walking
and breathing to things that you know
it's pretty clear something's wrong
thank you
hi I'm the amazing Jonathan and I'm an
alcoholic and a drug addict and wait a
minute wait wait wait what is this I've
done a lot in my life I mean and then 13
years in Las Vegas I had a great time
that greatest time of my entire life has
been here and I've made millions of
dollars I have two beautiful houses and
everything came crashing
down when I was told I had a year to
live it's not a joke so I'm dealing with
that right now I promised I wasn't gonna
cry but it's very scary and my heart is
failing my wife would have said it
failed long ago but it does actually
failing for real I can't do shows
anymore because my legs lock up and my
hands lock up and that's kind of shitty
for a magician but anyway I retired I
don't do shows anymore I did my last
shows at the Magic Castle I got my
affairs in order and that's it thank you
all very much for coming out
peace I see on the other side
he told me about his health condition
and you know honestly you know you want
to be first affected by it but it's kind
of a Andy Kauffman thing you don't
really believe it at first with Jonathan
they think it's maybe just a whole ploy
of his you know I still hope in my heart
that it's just that he's just kidding
about it the first three times
I heard Jonathan was dying did not even
consider it next three times I heard
jatha was dying I started to believe it
maybe the seventh time her John was
dying I was I was sincerely upset eighth
ninth tenth time kind of somber and
upset fifteenth time I don't think I
care anymore I think I think I think
he's lost I think I maybe have got all
my mourning out of the way I could just
enjoy Jonathan know what he does croak
it'll just be okay so he's dead now when
Jonathan got his diagnosis his doctor
had me in the room and he said I need to
talk to you for a second and I want you
to see this and he pulls up a video of
Jonathan's heart like an actual video
and it looked like a giant rock with
just the top little bit like this
flipping lickle and I'm I said well
that's weird how does that what a heart
does and he goes no actually the whole
hearts supposed to go and tried to
describe it to me and so I was the first
time I really understood how [ __ ] up
he really was
I met Jonathan before he was sick
technically though I didn't because he
was sick he just didn't tell me or let
me know about it because as someone
who's dating why would you tell someone
that you just start dating that you're
sick you have cardiomyopathy
that you have diabetes and you don't
control it so it was literally like two
weeks into dating him where I found
insulin Nielsen insulin I was like
what's this what's what what and he goes
oh I'm diabetic are you [ __ ] me I've
never seen you shoot insulin ever
oh it's cuz I don't bother then I find
all these pill bottles I'm like what
this hasn't been refilled are you are
you supposed to be taking these yeah but
I don't take those oh my god you're
gonna be taking these pills now and
you're gonna be taking your insulin
who's your doctor you know like I just
that's when I started prying into his
health because like he was not looking
after it this is Anastasia Canyon Valley
hello Jonathan's insulin again yeah and
you call me it's imperative that they
mail this today because if I don't he's
gonna be gone for two weeks without
insulin and Jillian should have called
this in yesterday thank you
I'm gonna give you the back of my hand
so basically after that he had someone
to grill him remind him to take his
pills remind him take his insulin fill
his pill box make sure he's taking it
and then he was in the ICU for ten days
and that really knocked some sense into
him they were like you can't stop taking
your pills Jonathan that's you're on all
of these for a reason I'm sick of taking
them well tough [ __ ] dude like mine you
got pills that are keeping you alive
take them gosh I can't even keep track
of how many I just dumped them cuz I
have a memory of what they look like and
where they go so potassium chloride this
has to be taken with first amide
metformin lyrica that's the first mine
carvanha lost in the statin he's on
another losartan walk the dog Fenno
fibrates levothyroxine spur on a lactone
an aspirin lisanna pill for Tantalus and
digoxin that is for the heart sir Helene
that's the a depressant yeah lots of
notes
Alma Frizzle we this is the funny pill
because this is the pill that he has to
take so he's a good sick of all good
so his lady she's running towards me
long blonde hair she's from Finland she
keep in mind I just been onstage as Joel
Osborne the whole time I get offstage
she's running towards me no it's you
it's you it's me no big deal no word of
a lie she runs straight up to me goes
can I get a photo with you Eric banner
how does that he all right
mid photos swear to god she turns to
because I just loved you in Wolverine so
I'm not standing in this photo thinking
not only she mistaken me for Eric banner
she's mistaken Eric Bana for Hugh
Jackman so when I heard about Jonathan's
condition what he was going through I
came out to the States
and stayed with him in Vegas here to
seeing that the difference in Jonathan
in terms of the vulnerability that he
would he would show and and allow to
come forth and we connected really well
during that time you know hanging out
and just having these open conversations
and he just looked so fragile you know
and I'd sing him in this light of
Jonathan's always been this big
dominating you know larger-than-life
strong character and he was kind of
hunched over but he was just standing by
the door and my heart really went out to
him just thinking he this looks you had
his
the weight of the world was on him and
he wasn't you know this is fragility to
him I walked up to him and I didn't say
anything just stood in front of him and
he put his arms and just wrapped his
arms around me just hugged me and said I
love you Cho
[Music]
none of the things I own the 25 classic
cars and all the tough stuff I thought
was so [ __ ] cool means nothing to me
now in fact if you want one
talk to me after the show there's not a
minute that goes by the view it doesn't
damage you have
you go on crying jags cried in the
middle of the night you start crying and
you can't stop get set
[Music]
right there by the side because eager
loving regardless you're not gonna let
him be alone
[Music]
[Applause]
biggest pain in my ass
yeah well don't have me so you're
leaving tomorrow for and when you come
into our club in the morning that's
winning it so they'd be gone for about
two weeks
then he's healthier he's not you know I
am passing out dough still that's just a
hard thing I don't leave this from your
blood infection yeah that actually looks
a lot better than I did before like I'm
gonna pay you cash now I yeah all right
I was told that I had was expiration
date so I stopped working and
concentrated on it just getting better
[Music]
when I stopped working I didn't know how
much people really liked you and until
you stopped working then you know
everyone comes out of the woodwork to
say you know how much how much the show
meant to them and and that's great to
hear I needed to hear that I feel good
enough to work again and I never really
wanted to stop working good luck on your
[ __ ] alright see you back in a few weeks
all right I need to bat poo back and
still go out there and do it first spot
I don't know if I can cuz I don't know
if I have the stamina to do it breathing
on my back
[Music]
trick entertainer whose bizarre humor
and antics have made him famous all over
the world we're talking about the
amazing Jonathan he is here with me in
studio because he's in town - maestro
it's a pencil it's not strong well yeah
I was given a year to have to live by my
doctor's and so I got it all prepared
and then three years later Here I am I
got tired of waiting around for it I
decided to go back out and do one one
last tour which is what I'm doing now
type of comedy in magic it does is very
very you know consuming of energy and I
could see where that could be a problem
that I I I hope he can judge it and kind
of balance balance it out if he drops
dead on stage probably be like the
coolest way to go out that's probably
the way he'd want to go out you know not
in some bed with an IV bla bla bla bla
bla I mean he want to go out
entertaining man so I think it's I think
he needs to I think it's a great idea to
be honest I think it's healthy because I
think it's a positive thing that makes
him happy I find that when he's on stage
and he's doing it he's just like nothing
else exists and I can see that I think
it's a fabulous idea
because he's so funny and it's like oh
it just it acts me to see him retired no
no I've heard a lot of people talk about
how much energy
it'll take Jonathan to do these shows
and how maybe you should be resting
never crosses my mind I think what
Jonathan should be doing is performing I
think you know Tiny Tim died on stage
doing tiptoe through the tulips I intend
to die in office the fact that Jonathan
is weak and feeble I don't think should
stop him at all it's hard for me to talk
about I'm just happy that he's lasted
this long be truthful with you
I feel great that he's gonna have the
opportunity to get back on stage and do
what I know he loves doing and do what I
know he's great at but that for me
though comes with a lot of worry and
concern my thoughts are that it's not
gonna work
dizzy when I stand up pass out dizzy
yeah I passed out twice yesterday I
passed out I haven't passed out in about
a year and yesterday it was a slow pass
out it wasn't like I'm pumping gas like
last time and I wake up on the ground
and it caught me as I was falling her
being very strong for me the best-case
scenario is just seeing him walk on
stage and having the strength to do that
the fact that he's just doing it is you
know for me that's the accomplishment
Joel I wanted to write letters to each
other I don't I know you wanted to do it
too so go ahead I'm ready for this just
don't make me cry no no it'll be did
Jonathan way to begin well at the
beginning I get very care little did I
know all those years ago as a 12 year
old the night my dad took me to see your
show that my life would never be the
same again seeing you take the stage
like a freight train that night it was
like nothing I'd ever experienced and I
know I wanted to be part of that world
I wanted on board not knowing where that
train was headed it was part of the
adventure and I can honestly say I never
could have predicted the different
destinations I'd experienced with you
over the years I wanted to talk about
the man I've come to know through
throughout my life not the amazing
Jonathan but the man I know Jonathan
zealous behind all the crazy drug taking
manic bravado I see something deeper
inside of you I see the kind generous
big-hearted caring person I know you to
be it's great to be back on the train
with you for one last ride my friend
I love you Joe that's nice I mean it I'm
glad so I can read this you okay crying
I make you really cry with this one this
one's gonna get you but I want you to
read the first part d Joel and I mean
not Billy not the piano man who is
really silly all right you and I have
accomplished a lot together we have made
millions of people happy at the same
time we mean we made each other happy
there's only one thing that feels as
good as being with your hero and that is
having your hero respect you as an equal
I consider you an amazing performer who
charms an audience brilliantly at times
you will put through the wringer with me
nobody skips that but you learn quickly
and you learn while having heaps of fun
too we both learned from each other and
I took away your ability to be patient
and treat people right watching how you
deal with people and kept the brand
strong you've not gotten jaded in any
sense of the form by this business and
you're still the sweet kid that you were
when you were a sweet kid and watching
that I'm watching you do comedy and just
makes me proud like I was your dad but
unlike your dad I'll always be there for
you so I love you
[Music]
why you got millions look it up that's
what I want to do when I grow up the man
who's coming to the stage was that God
that I saw
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen now actually I'll
sit back relax enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
round of applause for Joe Osborne
[Applause]
[Music]
come on out here yeah just one uh this
guy I met him when he was 12 years old
he was just a little kid and now he's
doing him stand-up that's amazing he
used to just watch and just learn he was
taking everything in I didn't know that
I thought you were gonna be competition
[ __ ] off
[Music]
[Applause]
I want them to leave thinking that's the
best shell that they've ever seen and it
is I'd say 90% of the people that come
see the show
will leave saying that is the most we
have ever left in our lives not just
this week or not just this month
whatever
just appreciate it and thank him for all
the laughs and just glad I get the same
well I've never got to see him before
but I'm a huge fan he helped inspire me
to be a street performer and I grew up
watching him a long time ago and he was
he did not disappoint
[Music]
[Applause]
other than your big about yeah the
scientists are limited because it's only
within the realm of what we as humans
understandable we so many and we make up
our religion into said the possibility
is is definitely not there I can't say
that well I can't because it's oh yeah
yeah here's the equivalent on them and
this has been proven the equivalent to
what we know about the universe out
there is equivalent to a glass of
science yes sir but science only knows
what's in this glass there is a whole
ocean out there that we don't know about
does this a that everything you know
said I come in with my grandma used to
say to me I don't see why anyone thinks
you're fine I don't get it she got sick
gradually and died
[Music]
[Laughter]
you